the
You
Hi.
Hello.
Okay.
Hi.
Hi. Yeah, you can't see me just yet. I know, uh, I know I'm invisible. Hi.
I'm so tired. I have not found my marbles just yet, but I forgot to change to
my headphones. I always forget to do that. It always plays on my speakers. Thank you
for the $2, um, super chat. Thank you. Yes. Yes, I've been working all day long
today. I've been working all day today. I worked all day yesterday and, um, I worked
half of the day the day before. So, today, while there's still some kinks that I need
to work out as I'm now just seeing, I wanted to show you basically the end
results basically of all my hard work. And I'll go more into it after I show you. Thank
you for becoming a member. Thank you. I love you too. Okay. Um, yeah, there's still some
small things I need to fix, but the end result will basically look the same from far away,
like to you. So, oh my God, I'm so excited. Okay. Wait, wait, wait, wait. You're not
fucking ready. Okay. Ready? No, you're not, but I'll show you anyways. Okay. We'll do
a whole reveal. Oh, oh, there's a top in my head. Maybe I should here. I'll go down here.
All right. The top of my head is bumpy as usual. I didn't change that. I still got my
headphone dent up there, but as we go a little bit, oh, I'm so fucking big. What the fuck?
Okay. As we go a little bit higher, wait a minute. Is it me? Oh, is it me? Is it me Ginger?
Wait a minute. She's Ginger. I'm actually Ginger now. I've embraced the Ginger and I actually
have freckles now. Not only have I embraced the Ginger, I gave myself more freckles, so they're
more obvious. Yeah. And then, and then there's more. Just wait, there's more. Are you ready?
So, I was told that not only my Ginger, but the bottom of my hair is supposed to resemble
pumpkins. And personally, I just never really saw it. So thank you for the $199 super chat.
So I never really saw pumpkins in my hair. So what I decided to do was make it more obvious.
I gave myself more obviously pumpkin hair. And I changed the jacket and the necklace.
You see it? I changed it. I simplified the necklace. This is all just kind of, well, not all,
but this is mostly to like my own preferences. But yeah, I changed the, I need lip balm. Thank
you for becoming a member. Crack racing. Hold on. Okay. Yeah, I changed the jacket. I wanted
something a little more, I guess something that fits the color scheme better. So yeah.
Um, are you gay? Why are you acting so gay? Mr. Sister Kisser Disco tip $6 and 90 cents.
I say this new model has soul but ginger. Mr. Sister Kisser.
That's so funny. That's so funny. Right. Yeah. Here's the jacket. This is how I changed it. It's
a little bit different than the original, obviously. And then I also changed the, it's
harder to tell. It don't, okay. The mesh on my body is a little different too. Like my mesh shirt.
Don't look too closely at it. That's one of the things I need to fix for sure. And don't
look too closely at my freckles either. But the mesh on my body is a little bit fucked.
Don't worry about it. I'll fix it when I have time. But yeah, I changed the mesh shirt a little
bit so it goes all the way up to my choker. And then I changed my thong. So the original thong felt
a little too thick. It kind of looked like um, it kind of looked like leather straps. And that's
painful to have against my Gucci. So I finned it out so it, you know, it looks more like a thong.
And I also changed the belt too. I just simplified that. And oh shit, look at that. The book is also
different. The book is a little bit, the book actually looks like it got, you know, mangled.
Okay. Where are you?
You're so gay.
Um, yeah, sure. Let me just show you the last thing that I changed. So I changed the color of the
shoes a little bit. And then I changed the knife. Yes. Let me see if I can pull up the other model.
I'm not sure. Maybe I can open a second VTube Studio.
Maybe I can't do that. Okay, wait, let me try something else. Let me try one more thing.
I'm not, I really, I'm not, like, I don't know much about VTube Studio and I'm not really good at
rigging. So I don't, I don't always know what I'm doing. I think this is the one I need.
I'm trying to bring up the old model too. Hold on.
Streaming assets items. And I put it in there. Maybe. Let's see if that worked.
Do I have to restart VTube Studio?
And we have to restart it. Oh, no, there it is.
I don't know if this is going to work. Uh-oh. Oh, there she is. Now there's two of me.
Right. There's two of us now. You can't escape. Okay, here they are side by side. I think I made
this one a little taller. There we go. So here they are side by side. Are you gay? Why are you acting
so gay? Oh, thank you for the, oh, I can't read that. Hold on, let me open the tab to read.
Email limits. Twins!
Um, hi little email till Big Bro's curious how much of Big Bro's samples would it take to
make your tramp stamp light up? Oh my god. I don't know. I don't know. Why don't we experiment
together and see how many it takes? Okay, yeah. So here it is side by side if you want to take a
screenshot. Um, I also slightly changed the, um, uh, can't think of the word. The shorts. The color
of the shorts is a little bit different too. Um, it's not a tramp stamp. Yeah, right. It's a
womb tattoo. It's not a tramp stamp. Get it right. Get it right. Um, the thong, some of the moments
are a little awkward, especially at the thong. Well, like I said, I'll fix it. I'll fix it slowly.
When I have time, because this was a little bit rushed, I really wanted to get it done.
You're shorter? Oh, that's, that's just me. There, now I'm taller. That's just the program.
I'm not actually any shorter. Okay, don't, don't try to, don't pretend I'm shorter. Okay, we're,
we're the same height. We're the same fucking height. Anyways, I'm going to throw old Jimmy away.
Bye-bye. Because I have something else to show you and it's even more exciting.
It's even more exciting. You're not ready for this one. This one's way crazier. Okay, ready?
Hold on. Let me, let me go change. Let me go change. Hold on.
Okay. I changed.
Oh, what's that? Oh, it's the Lord dress. Oh, I'm so tiny now.
It's the dress from the Lord video. Yeah.
This one, I also did myself. It's not very, like, it's not very wavy. Maybe I could,
maybe I could fix that too when I try to fix these. But, um, can I have the old Emmy?
No. Why are you acting so gay? What do you mean the old Emmy?
This Emmy will, it looks so much cuter. Look how cute it is. I really like it.
Can I have the old Emmy level? I think it might be illegal to have such a cute sister.
I kept the socks on. Even though in the Lord video, um,
even though in the Lord video, thank you for all the tips. I'm sorry. I'm trying to,
I'm trying to catch my train of thought. Thank you for the $5 super chat and the, the 420.
The style of your tattoo is called a badge badge. Okay.
Okay. Thank you for your 422. Mr. Kisser. Mr. Kiss. That. Mr. Sister Kisser.
Okay. Um, I forgot what I was going to say. I, I didn't have socks in the Lord video,
but I decided to keep the socks because I thought they looked like way cuter.
I thought the dress looked way cuter with the socks, you know?
So yeah. And I can, it's a little bouncy too.
I think I want to up the physics for, um, the dress a little bit. No,
because this is actually the first time I'm, uh, this is the first time I, I, I try it,
like I test it. Um, I'm here testing it with you. This is the first time I test everything.
I haven't tested it at all because I haven't been able to, um, export it into V2 studio.
Why are you acting so gay? Another sister kisser, tip $25. Hardworking little
sister deserves a small treat. The changes look amazing. The Lord dress is so cute.
You did such a great job. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. There's another sister
kisser. There's two sister kissers.
Thank you. Do you think tooth is adorable? It's always been adorable,
but now it's even cuter because it's probably a cute dress. Um,
someone get her some chalky milk. I don't like chalky milk, but you know what? I do have
some gamer subs. Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Thank you for the two dollars. Um, it kind of looks like, oh wait, that's not it. Your model
looks fantastic. I know you worked hard, so you shall be rewarded with lots of kisses.
Thank you for the two dollars. Um, kind of looks like a cute Halloween themed dress.
Does it look Halloween themed? The only thing that's Halloween themed is the socks,
which has, have some, um, have some, uh, catch up on them. They just have some catch up on them.
Why are you acting so gay? Rollo legend underscore 99 tipped five dollars.
You look so adorable. I love the dress. Can't wait to clap you less than three.
I guess you have easy access now.
Anyways, I finally got the, the, actually, no, I'll, I'll keep talking between,
I finally got the gamer, um, subs package and I know this kind of sounds like I'm chilling,
but I've always wanted to try, um, I've always wanted to try like these gamer juices,
but I, I could never buy them because they're kind of expensive for me,
especially if you're Canadian. Sorry, I'm not addressing my mic. If you're Canadian, they're
like, um, quite expensive, but that's just kind of everything for Canada, to be honest. Um,
American products are, uh, but the gamer subs animation. American products are often
like really overpriced for us, us poor Canadians. Um, I don't know if I have it.
Where is it? Is it here? Is it this? Yeah, there it is. We got a code. I'll make it small.
Like, there. But I just, I, like, this isn't even, like, you don't, don't even,
you don't, don't, don't worry about buying it. I genuinely just want to try it. Um,
I have all, I have low hole blast and then I have lean and then I also have, um,
Guacamole Gamer Farts 9000. Um, do you have any recommendations for anyone who's tried these
before? Why are you acting so gay? Blue Razz is my personal, I don't have Blue Razz,
I only have those three. Those were the ones that were sent to me. I want to spin you around
and dance to our favorite song with you in that dress. Aww. Should Big Bro get a tux or does
emo to like it when we dress like we're homeless? Like in the Lord? No, if you want to, if you want
to dance around, you should get a tux. Of course. You can't always dress like you're homeless.
You like lean or gamer fart? I'm seeing lots of lean or gamer fart. Which one do you prefer?
Which one do you think I'd like more? I like sweet things. Lean is the best? Gamer Farts? Gamer Farts?
Oh yeah, I forgot. Um, someone said we're so close to 20k. I forgot. Um,
thank you for 8k. 8k. Thank you for 18k. Thank you. That's, um, that's, that's, I didn't,
I'm not expecting to get, I don't know, every time we go up another K, I'm like, what the fuck?
I'm not expecting it. Yeah, we're at 18k already. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you so much. Um, I'm going to try lean because I think that's funny. Isn't lean the name of, um,
of a drug? 18.1? Yeah, 20k when? I don't, I don't know. I'm really, apparently I'm really bad at,
you know, um, guessing, like, I don't know. I'm like, I'm really surprised every time we keep,
you know, getting subscribers. It's probably mostly from that clip of my boobs, but I'm,
at least I'm glad that you guys like my boobs. It's not opening. Okay, there you go.
I got a taste of it when I opened with, I opened it with my mouth. Um,
so I have, oh, I got, oh, I got pure taste of it in my mouth. Okay, I got, um,
I got the cup itself and I think, um, I don't quite remember. I think, um,
I think I said three of the, of the spoon, of the spoons, the little spoon it comes
and into the cup, right? I might have to put a little less than three just because,
um, I didn't fill the cup up all the way. They add a grape drink to it.
It's one spoon for 250 milliliters. Yeah, that, uh, I don't know milliliters.
I don't, I don't know. I don't know how much I poured into my,
I have no clue how much I poured into my drink. There, I put one spoon. Did you eat, I'm like,
I did eat today. Yeah. One spoon for every eight Oz. I don't know Oz either.
I'll put two and then I'll see how it tastes and then if it's not enough, I'll put one more.
There. Okay, let me shake it around a bit. This is so cool. I don't know. I've had friends that
like, we're super excited about the waifu cups and stuff and I, I was always like,
confused what the hype was about. I guess I never understood it, but this is kind of cool. I'm
not gonna lie. Oh my God, it's pink. Yippee. 250 milliliters is about 8.4 ounces. Oh, thank you.
Yeah, we, they gave us a waifu cup. I don't, I don't know if this one has a name. Um,
but she has really big boobs and she's like punching the, she's punch, uh, she's like punching the cup.
Uh-uh.
Lena's purple. Oh shoot. Hold on. I'm like spilling it everywhere.
Okay, I think I mixed it good enough. Hopefully. I'm gonna use a straw.
All right, moment of truth.
Okay, two, I think was definitely enough for how much I put.
It, it, it's like, because it said it was grape, I was expecting it to taste like,
like great grape. Tell us the flavor. It's lean. The one that says lean on it. Lean.
Because you said it was grape flavored, I was expecting it to taste like great, but it, it,
like grape candy, but it doesn't taste like grape candy. It just tastes like real grapes. I was
surprised. Like it actually just tastes like, like, like, like a, it has, it has like the real
grape taste. I don't know, I was surprised. This sounds like I'm shilling it. Real grape flavor. I
don't know. I was, I was expecting like grape candy flavor, you know? Yeah, like actual grape
instead of candy flavored grape. I mean, I like both. I like both actual grape and candy flavored
grape, but that's interesting because I've never had a grape flavor drink that doesn't taste like
candy grape. Okay, I'll just be sipping on that while we talk. Hold on a second. Okay.
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay? May I please have an indirect sip?
An indirect kiss. You want some? Here.
Let me spit it up on you.
There's your taste.
Right. Um,
I'm just so happy that I was able to, to, to, to get it like, to use this model.
I'm so happy. I'm so happy. It was a lot of work just to rig it in the first place,
because like I said before, like, like the person who rigged this model definitely knows
a lot more about live 2D and making models than I do. So when I like opened the model, I was like,
oh, I had what the fuck is going on here. I was very confused. And so it took me a while to like
go through it and figure out what they did. I still don't know what they did for some stuff.
I'm still like, what the fuck is this supposed to do? I don't know. But it's good practice.
I guess it is. I don't know. I, I'm not someone that like, wants a career in rigging. So like,
every time I have to practice, I'm like, or not that I practice, but every time I do. Oh,
thank you for raiding, Strawny. Hello, didn't you do a karaoke? You had your bathtub stream
today too. That's so fun. Reefling raid. Hello. Hi, Reeflings.
I'm really impressed how well you did rigging and designing, especially in such a short amount of
time. You're so talented. Oh, thank you. Thank you. That's so sweet of you.
Um, Strawny's probably tired. She, she probably streamed a lot, huh? And she's saying too, singing
is tiring, especially for me. Singing is so tiring. Um, what are you wearing? A new dress.
A new hair. And, um, I had a lot of trouble like the physics. You see how like the leaves on the hair
move, you know, and, um, I, uh, this is such small, tiny details, but I wanted to show you because
I put effort into it. So, um, what I did was I separated some of the layers a little more.
So that way when I turn, you can kind of like see a little more shadow in the dress, you know?
Um, it's a little messy, but you know what? It's okay. And then not only that, but also in my hair,
um, I like made the hair turn, uh, it's kind of hard to tell. But in the bun, I made the hair, um,
I don't know. I made the hair turn more 3D. I don't know how obvious it is, but like you can see on
the sides when I turn, you know, the sides disappear a little more. I don't know. I don't know if you
can tell. It's a very small detail, but it's, you know, it's, it's a technique that I've been
wanting to try. And I think it looks really good. So, yeah. But I ran into a problem.
Thank you for the $2 super chat. Adorable. Thank you. I ran into a problem where at first,
I didn't know what the problem was. And, um, I had finished all my changes and I couldn't,
I couldn't export it and literally like fucking like half of, I spent all of yesterday working on
this and I, uh, half of yesterday, I got into a call with like another Vtuber friend and I feel
so bad for her because like she was talking to me and I was trying to pay attention so hard.
But at the same time, I was like internally raging because I was, I wasn't able to export
this and I kept raging at the freaking program. I feel so bad for her. She was probably annoyed.
But yeah, I spent like hours and hours yesterday just like sitting with the program opening,
like watching it not do anything. But the loading, the loading bar was there. So I was like,
maybe it's doing something. Maybe it's working. Maybe it's doing something. And I would just
sit there for hours and hours and it wasn't doing anything. And then finally, uh, finally today,
um,
hold on.
Finally today, I was like, okay, let me reach out for help. So I, I got over my shyness and
I, I usually don't like doing this, but I got over my shyness and I reached out to like
people who actually know what they're doing, um, making lies and I asked them for help and they
helped me and they helped me. And so I was able to finally export it. And the problem was that the
file was just too big. And I didn't know that. Well, I know that like they did make the model maker
made my file very, very, um, heavy on the computer and very large. I knew that, but I didn't know
it would actually cause problems, which is stupid of me to not assume that. But yeah, it caused
problems. So I had to, I did something. I don't know. I did a lot. It was time comes time, time
consuming, but I, I minimized it and now here I am and all of my cuteness. I'm so happy. I even
like this is something I never do with shoes. I like made the shoes turn a little bit and go up
and down. I don't know. It's such a tiny detail. It's not that big of a deal, but it's a big deal
for me as a rigging new bits of big deal for me.
Machine not beefy enough to survive the parts. It's not even my computer that was struggling
to export it because of the size. It was the literal live 2D program that was struggling
to export it because of the size. If that makes sense. Oh, thank you for the 10 gifted Silent
Night. Thank you for so much. That's so nice of you. Everybody thank, thank, whoever got a
gifted sub make sure you thank them. Um, I'm so proud of you. I'm just happy.
Cause I've been, um, I've been stressing over this. Like you have no fucking clue. I was like,
I tweeted out, I lose, um, I tweeted out that I was losing my marbles, um,
on Twitter and people were like, Oh no, what's wrong? And I thought people would assume that
it's, you know, it's the rigging, but some people didn't assume it. So they're like,
what's wrong? And it's like, I'm losing my fucking marbles over this model. That's what's wrong.
We're so proud of you for reaching out and getting it done. Thank you. I'm proud of myself too.
But, um, yes, of course the model got exported after all because I'm using it right now.
I'm using it. Of course the God exported it. You can kind of tell. Oh my God. I'm like seeing
all my mistakes now and I'm like, Oh, I don't like the mistakes.
And also here, I have something funny to show you.
So remember how I could take off my, um, my shoes before?
Well, so yeah, I could take off my shoes before, right? Now with this dress,
I am, you love the new model. It made me think of something. If you could make a sort of
concept art of how you imagine the standard big bro looks like, what would you imagine?
I don't think there's a standard big bro. I'm sure all of you are very different.
You kind of just got the hentai protagonist look in the, in the, um,
what's it called? In the lore video. Oh, thank you for the $4.27. That dress looks good on you.
It would look better on the floor. I worked hard to put it on. Don't take it off just yet.
Anyways, so my, my feet were actually really big and they were so big that I couldn't,
I couldn't fit them in my shoes. So, um, what I did instead was that I actually just cut them off.
I cut off my feet. So now my shoe toggle doesn't work anymore.
My shoe toggle doesn't work anymore because I cut my feet off so that they would fit into these shoes.
Sorry.
The nugget lore is real. I'm slowly turning into a nugget.
I'm very slowly turning into a nugget. Oh my God, it's real.
It's real. We're getting closer and closer every day to becoming a nugget.
I was just lazy and I was struggling so much with the feet. So I just, I just cut them off.
Yeah, now you got free armpits to sniff too. Think about all the places you can,
all the fun places you can shove those stumps now. What?
Effort towards the two models was worth it though. They look so good already.
Oh, thank you. Yeah, I, the reason I made this one, um, was because we had to push back the 2.0
to a year from now and I was like, why are you acting so gay?
Huh? Great job with the model. Big bro's very happy to see your hard work paying off.
Thank you. Thank you for your work. Are you gay? $50? Oh, I didn't see that. Thank you for the $50.
Link 3.22 tipped $50. Great job with the model, Emmy. Big bro is very happy to see your hard work
paying off. I'm having trouble keeping up with all the doughnuts.
I'm having trouble keeping up with all the doughnuts. Thank you for the $50 and also,
okay, the dress can stay on. Good. Right now at least.
Um, yeah, right. Um, so I was like, let me, let me do something at least.
If I have to wait a year, let me do something. So I did this and I think it's so, wait a minute.
Okay, no, I think that's just my monitor fucking up. Um, I think he's so cute. I'm very,
very happy that the model artist actually gave me a body underneath my clothes because otherwise I
wouldn't be able to do this. When I drop my models, I don't give them naked bodies underneath their
clothes because I'm really lazy. So, um, I'm happy that this one did. And I have a body underneath
here. Sheepies here? Wait, I didn't even see. Sorry. I have, I've been napping. How can my little
sister be so cute? I'm going to cry. Thank you, Sheepie. Thank you.
What's that thing where you have? What? What's the thing you have where small child is
lashed to your chest? What does that mean? What? I hear a lot of model artists put something under
clothes to make new outfits easier. Why are you acting so gay? Um, yeah, they do. They do. A lot
of model artists, well not all of them, but some of them will draw like the full body
underneath because it does make, it does make, um, new outfits easier. I just don't because I'm lazy
and that's extra work. I love the brush up. I'm going to lose it. Thank you. Thank you,
Sheepie. You're too nice. You better hold her close and cherish my little sis. Thank you.
You better hold me close too. You better cherish me too, Sheepie.
What else was I saying? I don't even remember.
I'm rushing in between my boobs. Please do. I'll motorboat them. I'll go
You have no idea how, like literally I've taken like no breaks. Streaming was my break between
making this. So I'm like, now I'm like, oh, I can relax. I don't have to stress anymore.
Ah, I don't have to stress anymore. It's been so stressful. Make sure you take a break,
a good break. I will. I, I did say that we might play, um,
I did say we might play poppy playtime, right? I kind of still,
Emmy was radio silent for like two days. Yeah, because I've been working on this.
Like I've been stressing over this. Like I've been, like I've been losing my fucking mind.
I've been losing my mind. I've been like crying. I've been yelling.
Ha, talented Emmy deserves rest. I'll rest after this. I will.
But yeah, I wanted to, I wanted to play some poppy playtime. I really do,
but I know I'm going to be hot and sweaty. Um,
I know I'm going to be hot and sweaty in my room. And if I play poppy playtime,
I'm going to like extend the stream by a lot because I want to finish poppy playtime.
So I probably will not play poppy playtime. You never have to push yourself that hard.
I want to. I wanted to. I wanted to. I did it. We're done now.
You have a bit more. Yeah. Okay. I'll just say here. Yeah.
Anonymous tip. $25. The dress is so cute. You did a stellar job.
Not to mention the revamped base outfit. Thank you. Thank you for the 25.
Play what makes you happy. We just want you to have fun. I will play what makes me happy.
Poppy playtime makes me happy, but I just, um,
I just don't think I have the energy to play it.
But I don't think I have the energy to play it. That's all.
But we'll play it again next week. Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Oh, I keep expecting the TTS to talk, to talk it, to talk.
The talk so I don't have to read. Why are you acting so gay?
Raven tipped $6.90. Thank you so much for all your hard work.
Here's a little kiss for your troubles. 40 minutes of Australian French kissing.
Australian? Why Australian?
You sound really drained. Like a way husband lifted off of your shoulders.
It has been. It has been. Like, I don't know how, I don't know how else to explain it.
I think I've explained it well enough. Oh, a kiss down under. Oh.
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay? I wasn't expecting that.
Um, um, why are you, um, thank you, uh, anonymous for the 420 big bro.
So proud of you. All your hard work was worth it.
Um, wasn't there another chapter of Andy and Layla? You can play that. No, there wasn't.
Was there? Yeah, there isn't another chapter. So, uh, no, I can't play that. Sorry.
I would, if I could, I would have totally, I, I want to, I want to, oh my god.
Thank you for the 20 gifted eternity. Oh,
this is, this is, this is, thank you. I don't know what to say.
I'll, I'll turn off that, that thing sound so it's not constantly digging.
Thank you. I'm really brain dead.
I missed up $10. Great job on the outfit and rigging yummy. It looks great.
Thank you. Thank you. Oh, and thank you, Flutterbox for the five more gift.
Thank you. Oh my god. You guys are so nice. It's because I complained.
It's because I complained about this. Now you're trying to make me feel better.
It's okay. You don't have to. Yeah, you're trying to spoil me.
Um, I really, really want to work on another, if I close this, will it break my rate? No,
I didn't. Okay. Um, I really, really want to work on a new video eventually, but um,
she be set in our discord server. Why is my little sister in me so cute?
Why is my girl failure dumb? So cute.
Oh, thank you. Pop in November for another five gifted. Oh, thank you so much for how the gifted.
Oh my god. How are the collabs coming along? So, um, I have not really gotten much progress
done on the collab with, um, Denpa. Unfortunately, I need to more, more. Oh my god. Thank you,
Flutterbox for another 20 gifted. Holy crap.
So many gifted today. Thank you. I guess we're gonna have a lot more people at our
membership streams now, aren't we?
Finally, a Frenchy Vtuber. I'm not a Frenchy. Oh shit. Thank you, Mr. Abby for five.
Why do you guys keep gifting more? Thank you. Basically whisper the 10 gifted.
Oh, I think these gifted are only for emails. Oh, you're right. You're right. Sorry.
You're right. You have to, um, I think you have to pay like $1 extra to get the actual membership
tier, but still thank you. Oh my god. Thank you, Saikai for the 10 gifted. Oh. Slow down,
slow down. Slow down. Oh my. Thank you. Thank you, Keek for the 20 gifted and Echo Sound for the
five gifted. Oh gosh. I wasn't expecting all of this. I, I didn't want to, yeah, it's Oprah Winfrey
kind of stuff. I didn't want to make a big deal out of the model reveal because I didn't want people
to like, I think it was some sort of, um, like big event that they don't want to miss out on
because it's like, it's not that big of a deal, you know, because I'll be using both of these
from now on. Oh, thank you, Gravy Baby for the 10 gifted and thank you for gone myth. It's because
you deserve all our money. I can eat ramen for another two months. No. No, no, no, no, no.
Don't, don't give me anything if you have to eat ramen for two months. Don't do that.
Thank you. Thank you the deathberry for, for 10 more gifted memberships. Oh gosh.
It's a huge deal because you're so talented and it's such amazing work.
Well, is this
okay? Thank you for $5 Anonymous. Um, it is a lots of stream. That's what we're doing.
Um, it's not that it's a big event. It's because people want to reward you for being such a hard
working, talented, cute little sister. Oh, thank you. Don't worry, Emily. There's Domino's regular
pizza for like $4 Canadian at my place. I just watched a Domino's crime video not too long ago.
You want to hear about that? What's crazy is that while I was watching the video,
I was eating leftover Domino's, which was funny.
Um,
nothing's wrong with ramen. Someone said, what's wrong with ramen though? Nothing's wrong with
ramen, but you know, people eat ramen because they don't have enough money for other stuff, right?
It's because you yelled and then you cried. So the pinpals are trying to spoil you for your
hard work. Thank you. Thank you for spoiling me.
Um, why does every stream turn into a true crime story kind of deal? Because I like true
crime. So I like telling you the stories. It was just, um, oh yeah, I got a gamers up some
noodle too. Do you want to try that together? We can try that together too.
Thank you for the $20 super chat. Why eat food when you can eat in me? Don't eat me.
Don't eat me just because I want to be a nugget doesn't mean you should eat me.
You want to try it together? Yeah, they do make noodles. I didn't know either.
I had no clue either. It's just chicken flavor, I think, but I don't know if it has like caffeine
in it or anything. I don't even know if these have caffeine in them. No, lean is caffeine free,
but maybe the other ones have caffeine. Um, I can't tell.
Oh, thank you for the hundred bobs. I don't know what Bob is. First time watching you live,
here's some texts for the cultured audios I listened to on Patreon. Thank you. Ah,
thank you for the texts. That's gross.
Um, I guess I can go microwave it real quick. It's pretty quick to make 100 whole bobs.
I'll go microwave it real quick and we can eat it together.
So I'll be back in like two seconds, not two seconds, like two minutes.
Okay, B or B, I'll probably pee while it microwaves. I'm gonna turn this off. I don't,
I don't really like showing advertisements on my streams that much. It's pissing time! It's pissing
time! All right, I'll be back with noodle.
Okay, you guys weren't saying anything while I was gone, right?
You weren't, sorry, it took me a while. It took me a while. I did not, I did not
microwave the cup like it says on the packaging. I know, I know it says not to microwave it.
I did not microwave it. Um, how are the noodles? They're still like, I have the cup here. They're
still um, softening. They're still softening. Um, were you fantasizing about the flavor of
eminade? Did you wash your hands? Of course I did! Yes, I did. Good girl, thank you. I read the packaging.
I was gonna put it in with the packaging. Like, I was gonna put the whole cup in there, but um,
I made sure to read it beforehand, and I didn't. What color was it? I didn't look! Do you look at
the color of your pee? Do you look at it? Are you like one of those, you missed 10 more subs from
our hero? Oh, shit. Um, thank you for the $1 super chat while I was gone, and thank you,
Diane, uh, Diane Nysos for the 10 gifted, and thank you for becoming a member. Okay,
that, that one good guy. It's kind of a default for guys. You do look at the color of your pee.
Oh yeah, you can't really look away. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I kind of just, you know, well,
you could sit down. You can sit down. Why don't you sit down? Wait, we're not supposed to put it
in the microwave? Oh, not this brand, not the Gamer Soups brand. I like how they said added MSG
for delicious taste, because a lot of companies are really afraid of adding MSG, because fucking,
um, I don't know what happened. I probably wasn't even fucking born yet when the world was like,
oh, MSG causes cancer or something like that. I don't know. I like MSG. I think it tastes good.
What if the pee is brown? I guess that's bad. Standing up is our God given right? The flow
is better standing. Is that true? I don't, I don't believe you.
Aw, thank you. Thank you for the four dollars and 20 cents. Ah, shit. I should have not opened that.
But, um,
if, if little Emmy now has pumpkins in her hair, then Big Bro will have lots of fun digging it.
That's kind of hot.
Digging inside you and carving your insides with his tool, with his tool.
Standing just makes you feel powerful. Uh, why do you want to feel powerful though?
Let's cringe. You feel powerful when you pee? Hmm? You like being, feeling powerful when you pee?
I mean, I had a heart attack unrelated to MSG after eating food with MSG,
so the salt industry blamed it on MSG. Yeah.
Let me smell it. Let me give it a nice snort. It looks so little compared to the amount of noodles
in the cup. It does, it does smell good. I usually like a lot of powder.
I feel powerful avoiding taxes. Yeah, that's what, that's what gives me power.
Avoiding taxes. Not, not standing while, um, pissing.
Um, if I sit down to pee, my starship trooper keeps touching the inside of the toilet because of the
link and I, and I'd rather avoid that. Skillish you. That sounds like a skillishie to me. I don't know, man.
Well, thank you for the 333. Um, Amy, I just saw the thumbnail. Why'd you call me out like that?
Wait, wait, why'd I call you out? Gamer soups, it's just soup. It doesn't have any of the, um,
it doesn't have any of the, I can't remember, like the, there's no vegetables, which makes it extra
gamer. There's no vegetables, which makes it extra gamer. Um,
but that's what I like. Like, you know how some come with dehydrated vegetables?
I always throw those out. I never use those. I don't like vegetables in my noodles.
Okay. Flavor wise,
I like to look drink, but I think this could use more flavor. It only has a little bit of
spice when you, when you eat the noodles themselves. I only tasted a little bit of spice.
Very little sister behavior. She hates vegetables. I do hate vegetables. Um,
Amy, going for a scurvy speed run. I go through, I won't, I don't get scurvy because I go through
these phases where I eat like a lot of oranges at once every few months, right, right before my body
like feels like it's going to get scurvy. It craves a bunch of vegetable, not vegetables, oranges.
And then I buy like a whole bag of clementines and finish them in a day.
I hope nothing fell out.
Is it supposed to be spicy? I don't know. It says artificial chicken flavor.
It's, it doesn't, I guess it's kind of, it's kind of tastes like chicken.
Wait, I need to run.
That's why your hair is ginger. Yeah, I guess. I'm so happy it's finally ginger though.
I wasn't denial that it's ginger because it looked so blonde, you know, and now it's ginger.
Do you like spicy food? I do. I do like spicy food. This isn't very spicy though.
This is like, okay, the drink I'd rate it like, okay, I'm very picky. I'm a very, very picky eater,
okay? Just so you know, the drink I'd rate like an eight out of 10, like is pretty good.
The noodles I'd rate like a seven out of 10, maybe even a six.
Am I allowed to say that? It's good.
But I feel like,
I say it as I like scarf it down. Hold on. Okay. Noodle drama.
Amy gets dropped for rating the Gamer Sub's Noodle a seven out of 10.
They do put a lot in it though, which I appreciate. They definitely squeeze a lot in the small cup.
Because some, choking, because some companies will like do that thing where it looks like it's full,
but like at the bottom, they cut it off, but they put a shit ton of noodles in this cup.
I did try one of the energy bars. It was all right too.
Yeah, they do that half cup thing, but this one had a lot of noodles in it. I got it on my glasses.
Stranny was making me feel colorblind, calling the last year not fun. Me too, dude.
Me too. I think, I think Stranny might be a little bit colorblind.
I think she might be a little bit.
Like maybe just a little bit. I don't know. Or maybe the artist was a little bit colorblind.
Maybe they're both, maybe they both have the same kind of colorblind.
Um, because it was definitely, definitely blonde. It was a bright, bright blonde before,
but now it's definitely, definitely orange.
I feel like I still got splatters on my glasses. She was definitely coping.
Thank you for the $20 super chat.
Wait, I think these are old super chats that I'm hearing right now.
Yeah, these are old. Oh, sorry. It's now saying some old super chats in my ear,
but you haven't muted, so you don't hear it. In response to my last donation,
I meant that the title of the stream says, I bet you like kissing your sister.
I know. I know. I, I chose the title of the stream. I know what the title of the stream is.
You better be kissing your sister. I still have fucking droplets on my, what the fuck, on my glasses.
I'm, I'm breathing on them to wipe them.
Okay, whatever. I don't care anymore.
Yeah, the gifted subs are delaying the streamlabs. Don't know. Yep. Yep.
Okay. The concept art was a lot more ginger, which is what Strani was going off.
The artists definitely tried to make it blonde though. I don't know if they tried,
but yeah, the concept art was ginger. The model art was blonde for sure.
I love her so much, but her colors.
Recalling Strani over being colorblind.
She knows the title, but not what the color of her hair always was. Well,
I don't know. I was just confused cause I saw, I saw the concept art.
Oh, let me pull it up right now. Cause I feel like,
I feel like even the concept art switched from blonde to ginger too.
I feel like that was the case too.
Am I allowed to show my Google drive here?
I think I'm allowed to show the concept art.
And let me download them all. Download, download. I think Strani showed a good amount.
I'll show some of them, not all of them. Move over. Download. Download. There we go.
You do what you want. Yeah. Fuck the rules. I do whatever, whatever I want.
Is that a recent donal? It was. Okay, good. I can turn that back on.
Someone took $7 or $6.09. Thank you. It's easy to aim the hose while standing,
unless little sis wants to hold it instead.
I do want to hold it. Please let me hold it.
Please. Okay, let me show you then.
So I think the first concept was this. Oh, that's really big. It was this.
Which looks nothing like me. And by she's ginger, for sure. She's ginger here.
Did you do a helicopter with it? I saw a story. Why are you guys so gay?
It was a TikTok comment, I think. Oh, my phone's dying.
Shit, my phone is dying. Okay, it was a TikTok comment and it was like,
my husband doesn't let me hold it while he pees anymore because right before he pees,
I started to helicopter it and then he started peeing and it went everywhere,
which I think is really funny. Her name for Foster's? Yeah, Foster's home for,
I know who you're talking about. I know who you're talking about.
Something, I know, I know what you're talking about. Someone else said that too.
For imaginary friends.
I look like the red-head girl from Foster's home for imaginary friends, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
Women don't know what kind of weapon they're dealing with in those situations.
Her name is Frankie. I look like Frankie, for sure, especially like the ponytail
and the sweater too. Straight jorking it on.
Wow, we're not doing anything extra cool.
Thank you for the five dollars though. But this is ginger for sure.
And then I think, you know, we kind of had this, which is definitely ginger too.
And then they eventually got to like the current outfit, which is not downloading.
Allow.
This is the current outfit. That's not the current outfit.
Which one is the current outfit? Well, this is basically the current outfit, except with the
colors. But this is still ginger, but this is when it stops being ginger.
Here is where it stops being ginger. This is where I got un-ginger-fied and blonde-ified.
This is the culprit. You can see, I don't know who, I don't know which artists these are.
But also on tanned, I was never tanned in the first place. I don't know what happened here.
I was never supposed to be tanned, I don't think.
But yeah, this is where I got un-ginger-fied. And maybe this is what was shown to the model
artist. I have no clue. And that's when they created this. Why is the brightness so high on that?
I don't know. But that's when they created that. And this is blonde for sure. Blonde-ification.
The blonde-ification of a ginger.
And obviously the shorts are a little different. This isn't the finished model art or anything.
The head really swelled over time.
It's just the art style, okay? It's just the art style. Shut up, I don't have a big head.
I have a lot of thoughts, okay? I got a lot of stuff going on up there.
I mean, with a tan, it's kind of nice.
If you like a tan, go to Shibi. Shibi's getting tanned soon. They're gonna tan her up.
I'm sticking my tongue in the package for the powder. I don't think I'll ever go tan, though.
Even for like summer models? I guess this could be considered like a summer model, right?
This could be considered like a summer model because I got like a cute sundress.
Who is Shibi? Come on, don't say you only watch me. Don't say you only watch me.
You have to know the other girls at least. At least know their names.
It's more of a fall vibe? I think it's a fall vibe because of my hair.
My hair is very much giving fall, but I feel like the dress itself is giving summers and not.
I don't know. I feel like it is.
I feel like it is. I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know any other girls.
But I think it would be really fun to like make more outfits. Maybe like um,
obviously they're all going to be scuffed because I made them.
I know we're doing one beamed outfit for everyone for a specific
holiday? Holiday? Is it a holiday? I know we're doing one beamed for everyone for a specific holiday, but
um, I forgot what I was going to say.
But because I have, you know, the ability to make more, why not make more? You know,
why not make more? It's fun.
I mean, I was hella stressed, but look, the end result is fun.
Rat costume for Halloween? Maybe.
Halloween fit? Possibly. Maybe even a Christmas fit too, but I think Christmas fit. I don't know if
we'll all do Christmas fit. Christmas fit might just be my doing. I might just do it myself.
I don't know. It might be really stressful for me.
But it could be worth it. Santa's slutty little ginger help.
No, I don't want to make it slutty. I don't want to make it slutty.
I'll try to take it easy. I'll try. I don't know. I don't like to, I don't really like
slutty outfits that much, not in real life or like on my models, so.
Elf? Elf would be cute. I could make my ears like long.
A gingerbread girl? That would be cute too. That would be really fitting.
You gotta give us at least one slutty outfit, but I don't know. I don't like slutty. I feel like
I feel like even my, um, my 2.0 is pretty slutty. Like, it's slutty for me.
Like, how much slutty do you want me to go?
Oh.
You know, like my current, like, like this outfit, this outfit is pretty slutty too.
Is it not slutty?
All I want for Christmas is my little sister.
Why are you acting so gay?
You'll get her. Don't worry. Maybe I'll stream on Christmas. I don't know.
I don't know if I'll be visiting my mom or not for Christmas. We'll see.
Um, thank you for the ten dollars and thank you for the three dollars anonymous.
Your brother likes them. Isn't that enough to wear at least one or two?
Please pleading face?
Um, you could 100% do a nightmare before Christmas style outfit. Mix of Halloween and Christmas stuff.
But I already am doing a Halloween outfit and I already decided what it is.
Um, they mean they want big boobs. Oh, I can't do that. No.
I don't, I don't want to, um,
I don't know. Just personally, I don't think it's a good idea for me to change my body type,
um, for my model. I think it'll take away, like, the recognizability of myself, if that makes sense.
Like, people recognize the character, you know?
And if I change the body type to have big boobs and big, big, big, big, I don't know, big hips and big eyes.
There is sexiness in the imagined. Want Timmy in a full non-outfit. Telling me I've signed.
Telling you you've signed. You've signed.
Signed?
Yeah, it seems like some of your removable shorts. It's not allowed on YouTube. Even Strani and, um,
Strani and Mercy have to cover their, their crotches because it's so, like, revealing, you know?
No.
Signed.
Thank you for the five dollars and the, the other five dollars.
I think there is a non, a non-outfit on Booth that I can buy.
It could be a big sis version. I don't know.
I don't know if I'd want a big sis version, though.
On your birthday, can we get a birthday suit? No.
Why did they make models for a YouTube company that they can't show on YouTube? Is it a statement?
I don't know. I mean, they can show me on YouTube perfectly fine. And they can show I see on YouTube perfectly fine.
Um.
It's not all of us, but that's okay because we're getting, um, Azir is getting a cover up for her giant boobas.
Now don't worry. Don't freak out just yet. Don't, don't, don't go crazy. Don't freak out.
You'll still see him. You'll still see her boobs. I know. I know it's scary
and you might be thinking, oh my god, I'm never gonna see Azir's boobs ever again.
You'll still see her boobs.
Um.
It's just, um,
not as like
obvious, I guess. I saw what it looks like. It's very cute. It's very, very fitting for her, um,
for her design.
But she constantly has to wear, um, like, I think she uses like a,
uh, what's it called? Let me see. She uses like a boba cup or something, right?
To cover her boob crack.
I'm checking her stream right now.
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Oh, she doesn't use it anymore.
She used to, or maybe she's just covering it by going really low on the screen.
That could be possible, too.
I don't know.
Um, honestly, the gap between your cuteness on YouTube and your sweatiness upstream is the
best gap in the way ever.
Okay, Lee, I need you to explain gap in the way to me. I don't know what it means. What does gap in the way mean?
Um, thank you for the two dollars, though.
The full models are for member streams. Oh, that makes sense. That makes sense. If you want to see the goods,
you got to go on the membership streams. If you want to see their naked crutches.
Covered can sometimes be hotter than open.
Yeah, I agree. Yeah, you're right.
I underestimated how severe YouTube was gonna be. Needed the models to meet the vibe for the company. That's probably it. Yeah.
So for me, I feel like I would have been fine. Like,
I'm definitely a covered is more sexy than revealing kind of person.
Just a little tease, you know? Just a little tease is good enough for me.
As long as it's fashionable.
Gapmoy is the difference between how someone acts such looks in one context and act such looks in the other.
Someone who has one attitude, then suddenly they have another more endearing one.
Oh, it means the cute effect when someone does something unusual.
Strani with a lollipop model would be another case of Gapmoy. That would be so cute. I think a lot of people want that.
Like a serious office lady, but in private, she's really cute and childish and sweet.
I'm not serious on Twitter, though. I guess I am a little different.
Mercy has gap between her dorkiness and her yandere behavior. People find it cute. Mercy is cute. She's very, very cute.
Lolli mode for every girl. I'm not gonna spoil anything, but
it would be funny.
It would be funny.
I don't know if like, because if the other, if we do like um, okay, it's getting more spicy now because I'm going home, um,
I'm getting the liquid only. I ate all the noodles already.
I think it would be funny if we switched roles in like all of the like other girls when Lolli
and um, me and I see went like big boobie girl as like a joke, like a
like a one-time thing, like a
like an April Fools kind of thing, but I don't even know if I see who would want to do that.
Yeah, like April Fools
I don't know if she'd be up for that. I would be up for that because I think it's funny.
Yeah, I'm gonna drink the liquid now.
Although liquid is definitely more spicy.
Age progression.
It probably wouldn't be a great quality model, obviously, if we're only gonna use it for one day.
It'd probably just be like a little silly joke.
I feel like it'd be silly to like, oh gosh, really spicy in my throat.
It'd be silly to like spend a bunch on a one day kind of model. Yeah, like the NGTubers.
Something like that. Maybe I have no clue what their plans are. I'm just speculating. I'm just speculating.
This was good. This was really good. I haven't eaten much.
I ate breakfast. I ate breakfast and then I worked on the model the whole time until I started streaming, so I was kind of hungry.
But I'm done now. Yippee!
That was lean? No, that was the rest of the noodles.
Um, can we get the dress back? Full Cunny vibes? Sure. Here you go.
Hey guys, sneeze a little bit.
No, not yesterday. Today, today, today. I only ate breakfast and then I kind of just worked on the model the whole time until stream. That's all.
Not yesterday. I've eaten since yesterday. Don't worry, I've eaten since yesterday.
I'm not the kind of person that that skips meals or anything. Don't worry about me. I don't do that. I'm, I'm Abby Eaton.
I remember, I was talking to the most, I don't know when it was, but she was like, oh,
are you the kind of person that like lets your lights go off, but makes sure that you're like eating good? And I was like, yeah.
I'll, I'll let them turn off my, my electricity and my water before I start skipping meals. You fucking bet, you fucking bet your ass.
I, uh, I'm not the kind of person that skips meals ever.
Or at least not anymore.
Which model with a sexy mode slash spell toggles? What is a sexy mode? What do you mean by that?
Are you a mimosa or the big eaters? It's adorable.
Ever since I met like all these other, um,
like company vtuber girls, it's like a whole other world.
It's like completely different from, uh, from indies. Cause like, I feel like everyone knows each other.
Everyone like knows, like everyone's in talks with each other. Everyone's friends with each other. Everyone knows what's going on with each other.
But it's like, because not a lot of companies want to associate with us, I'm like finding out from like my one friend that knows from other girls.
And I'm like, whoa.
Sorority vibes, yeah.
Um, do you think it's possible for a sexy model stream in the future? You want sexy so badly from me? I'm not here to be sexy. I'm be, I'm here to look cute. What do you mean?
Oh
My god, uh, yeah, also I'm already sexy. What do you mean? I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't even have to try.
Uh
Yeah, the shoulders are so so so so eggs. I can't say I feel like I shouldn't say sexy too much
Exy
Oh
It's weird how surprising
It's weird how surprisingly connected different groups are. Yeah, like it's way more connected than the indie
um
I feel like it's more connected than indie because obviously there's way more indie people than there are like people in companies which makes
Sense that makes sense
But it's like
Everyone knows each other
Which is cool
Because I don't know anyone
I'm not really one to like reach out to people too much. So that's probably why I don't know that many people
Mercy knows everyone though
Mercy was like, oh, yeah, um blank from this company. I used to be friends with them before they joined that company and I was like, huh?
How do you know all these people? How are you friends with all these people before they joined companies? What the fuck?
What the fuck
I don't know what people are asking for when they mean sexier. I don't know either like lingerie
Or something
Turned on by her neck
You like my neck it can get really really long if I like
Do that
It can get pretty long
Yes, mercy is very connected. I'm surprised she hasn't done more outside uh collabs, but maybe the
Oh my god, my freaking I got a bug bite on my foot and it's so itchy
It's like so bad that it it's caused a scab and I'm like
Itching the scab because it's so itchy
If it two hands you bet you you bet it can
Oh sexy stuff for other site stuff
Um
Probably not
Other sites don't allow it. I don't know what to tell you
And I'm not gonna stream on like a site that is not a popular or mainstream
Scab picking ASMR. Oh my god
No, no, I can't do that that would be fun
That would be fun, but I can't I can't I shouldn't I shouldn't I can't encourage it. It's not good
Don't encourage it in me
Oh my god, Kai foes streaming right now
Should we go raid Kai foe? Oh, she's crocheting. I didn't know she knew how to crochet. What the fuck?
If you don't know Kai foes a friend of mine, and I'm also her model mama
You could just say it's roleplay that's not gonna stop me from getting banned. What do you mean?
I think we might go raid Kai foe
It's not that I want to leave you but I'm not I'm hot and I'm also tired and um
I forgot what I was gonna say
I have a stream tomorrow, right? Don't I don't I have a stream tomorrow
There's another exciting thing happening tomorrow the uh, there's the
I didn't know you were a model mama
I'm a model entire parental unit, but um, it's mostly from when I was like a beginner
So I don't think that they're that great
But yeah, I just don't I don't like really talk much about it, but yeah
Yes, I'm the whole parental unit I've done it all I've birthed many children out of this tired tired couch
I have reproduced asexually yep. Mm-hmm
maybe like
Five I don't know
Maybe it's five. I don't know the whole number. I don't I don't keep track
After a couple hours like the appeal came from the forbidden love role play thing
Also, keep your ac slash fin on during streams. It's about noise. You stay cool
Okay, well, I care about noise, but thank you for the five dollars
Uh came from the forbidden love role play. Yeah, I did come from that too
I think people just want more they're kind of whores. They're kind of sluts and they want more
Any pregnant heart
This is a mother of how many yeah, I have lots of kids I do
And let me see
Let me count how many kids I officially have
From my own kunani
And made by myself
Um
Because I made models to buy a computer
One two three four
So four and then if you want to count myself
It's five that I've made completely by myself and then I'm
Um
And then I'm two more people's model mamas only so that means I only did their art and I didn't do the rig
Yeah
That's it
Are we getting a 20k celebration stream? I don't know
I still have to do the art for for 10k
I still have to do the art for 10k
Hey
What do I do new tags loli milf sister wife yandere
What do you mean new tags?
You want me to be a milf? What are you giving me these tags?
I did not drew um this model. I did not draw this model. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I meant like my other model the spider model
I did not draw this one
No, I can't take credit for this one. No
10k was the feet feet
The feet
The what
Integrate the 20k art into the 10k art
I could just can I move the the the 10k art to the 20k art
Feet for 20k did I say that feet cam have I said this before?
What
Are you like gaslighting me right now?
I swear I've never talked about feet cam viacam
The perfect groove
What
Celebration
Did I say I'd do a feet cam for 20k?
The thigh cam was strongy
I know I would never say I would do a thigh cam, but maybe I would say I would do a feet cam
You did drunk toe painting back or way back already. Yeah
Rat cam I can't do a rat cam because they're constantly moving around the cage
um
And it would not be very easy to see them if I did like
A full cage cam. I don't know the cage is also very busy. So it's very easy for them to just
Not be visible to you
um
Sit back and get groomed to me, huh?
Rat race I can't do a rat race. They're not gonna want to listen to me telling them to race each other
um
We could do a foot some kind of foot stream though. I think that would be cool
I don't know. I don't I'm scared to plan for 20k because I feel like
I feel like the growth is gonna stop and we're not gonna get to 20k that soon
But that might just be me being pessimistic. I don't know. You know, I mean
We're looking forward to the 20k feet cam. Okay. Okay. We'll do a 20k foot cam. Okay
Okay, it's not gonna be tomorrow. It's not gonna be tomorrow. Um, but we'll we'll do a 20k foot cam. I'm not sure what
I'm not sure what I'll do with my feet. Um
I've drawn chat
Request was my with my feet before and that was really fun. Would you want that? Should I reuse my old idea?
Do you want me to
You're doom posting. I know why I am I am the doom poster
I doom post everything
I'm dooming my whole my whole every single thought I have is a doom post. Okay
You don't know how much I've stopped myself from tweeting doom
Um, yeah, we're using content. Yeah, do you want me to do like some kind of drawings with my feet? Do you think that'll be fun?
You could do what strani did for ASMR. I don't think I want to copy strani
Popping cooking but feet only I don't have the dexterity with my toes to do that
I
Tweet more doom posting. No, I don't want to worry people. I don't want to worry people
Literally just me saying that I lost my marbles had people would like being like, oh, I hope she's okay
I'm fine. I'm fine. I was just going a little crazy over the model, but I'm fine
So I don't want to doom post
You want me to oil up my feet
You want to make me all shiny
How am I supposed to hold the the markers?
How am I supposed to hold the markers if they're all old if my toes are all oiled up and and slippery?
You want me to oil up my feet?
Oh an apartment tour would be cool too
An apartment tour would be cool too. Okay. How about this?
I kind of have to fart, but I'm not gonna fart in the mic
How about this? Um
How do I
Um, how do I go back to youtube here?
You can choose between
Wait, you can choose what we do for um 20 k. Okay
You can choose what we do
Okay, I'm gonna put a poll
So we're either going to
Do an apartment tour now. This isn't going to be me walking around my apartment with a camera
Um, that's like live. That's way too dangerous. Uh, that's not gonna happen
I will probably just take photos of everything and try to be as like in depth as possible
And then I'll show you the photos on stream. Okay, so I'm not going to be walking around my apartment live on camera
Um, that's too dangerous. So it's either in an apartment tour
I'll make sure to pixel me
Just to specify because I don't want people to choose apartment or thinking that's what it'll be and then um
Oiled up what feet? I got oiled up drawing with feet
Okay, um
What should we do for 20 k there start pull
Feet will win. I don't know
Okay, yeah feet is winning
When did you lose your marbles should we go find them? No, don't worry. I I'm slowly getting them back
It's Johnny collab thumb style toe war what?
Do you want me to collab with straw me for 20k? We can do that. I haven't done that yet
I kind of want to do an ASMR collab with straw me. She's been doing ASMR collabs with everyone except for me
I'm kidding. I'm kidding
I think that'd be cool
Um
Oh, shit, it's kind of close. It's kind of close
We'll get there eventually I think she is doing an ASMR collab with all the girls eventually she was writing that once I remember
Your feet guy
Maybe the apartment tour can be like uh 30k
Uh 30 k sound so far away though. I'm sorry. I don't know
I don't know like I don't I I don't know how fast the growth will continue
So I don't want to be like I don't want to say 30 k in case 30 k is in like 10 months, you know
I don't know
Okay, it seems like the oiled up drawing with feet um one
So
I will
Draw try to draw with my feet for 20k, I guess
I'm tempted to I don't know. I'm tempted to just like buy that fancy vlog camera myself
Because I really really want good quality for handcams and stuff. Um
Because I'm gonna do so many of them, you know
But yeah, 30 k will be apartment tour and then um 20 k will be drawing up drawing with my feet
25 k in three weeks revealed to me in a dream
Yeah, okay, I believe you I believe you sure sure sure
I
Feet cam apartment tour, that's not even an apartment tour. That's a floor tour
You want me to show you my dirty ass floors? You don't want to see my floors. They're so gross
I like never fucking mop. It's really gross
And I definitely don't vacuum as much as I should
It would be it would be a floor tour
I'll show you all my disgusting dirty dusty like
My gross floors
You never hire a maid. What the fuck kind of
What the fuck kind of millionaire do I look like hire a maid?
hire a maid
Like a topless maid maybe but no
No, I would not I don't I don't hire maids
Do you guys hire maids? Is that a thing? Is that like common? I thought that was like a like a fancy person thing
Dirty floors is what you want. You want to be my topless maid. Do you want to be my topless maid?
No, not topless by just legs. I mean topless like without a shirt
A maid cosplay while you do the tour
What do you mean?
You made I could do a cleaning stream
Where I dress up
In a maid cosplay and just clean my house
I don't know
Why aren't you the topless maid?
Because I don't want to be you should be the topless maid. It's your job to take care of me, right?
So at least entertain me while you do it and get topless
Maybe it's a yeah, maybe it's a cultural difference thing. Maybe some cultures hire maids more commonly than others
Here in Canada, it's not really common to do that
You
Chat being the Lulu as usual
Stroni hired a maid
Oh
They're after me
Police are after me
I just heard sirens as she should Stroni works very hard and I'm sure she doesn't have a lot of time to be cleaning
What's the hourly rate um a kiss on the forehead every hour
Every hour you work for me. You earn one kiss on the forehead. That's your rate
What if I wear nothing but an apron? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, you can wear a naked apron till
To clean that's a little more dangerous. So what if you use like dangerous cleaning products?
You don't want to be naked sitting, you know getting bleach all over your skin or something
50 per minute. Nah, you're too expensive. I can't favor that. I can't favor 50 per minute
No
Touching is extra. Okay, touching can be one extra per hour. Okay
It's so easy to groom you into what I want. It's so funny
I they make one joke
About liking watching boys kiss and everyone suddenly turns gay and then I make one joy joke about you being my topless maid
And now you're like topless. Why why don't I just be naked?
Why topless let me just let me just get fully naked
Oh
Kisses on the feet be bonus incentives. You want to kiss you want me to kiss your feet?
What?
I guess as long as you clean them clean your feet
No, I'm not complaining. I just think it's cute and funny
I just think it's cute
I
Okay, um
Let me raid I just want to make sure because I think I am gonna end here
Oh, and I just want to make sure that this person is not ending their stream
Before I raid because that would be awkward
I'm getting an advertisement for
This is a Tim Hortons advertisement. What is this for?
Maple bacon breakfast sandwich. Holy shit. This one's delicious. Okay. Okay. She's not an extreme. Okay. I'll read her
I had Tim Hortons for breakfast today. I wanted to get a bowl, but they ran out of rice
Um
Like wrong thing
Chibi slash Azura is in four minutes. Oh should I wait for them instead?
Maybe I should wait for them instead
Or here I don't have to wait. I can just redirect you in like into their chat
Um
Are you sure are you jobbing me right now?
I
Are you lying to me right now?
What do you get oh my god, um a beef
Sandwich, I don't remember the name
Why it was like a beef and cheese. I didn't it was okay. It was all right
Not what I usually get though
Live chain together. Oh, I think maybe I didn't recognize the the thumbnail
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. I got this. I got this. I got this hold on
still a youtube noob
Oh
Okay, I'll read Azura
So that way you can go support Azura because we're all trying to get to 10k. So please go
Chibi's already at 10k. So that's why I'm not reading her but we want to get Azura to 10k too
So please go subscribe to Azura and and and go watch her and you can go jerk it to her voice too
But don't tell me about it because then I'm going to cut your dick off. Um
I'll see you tomorrow because I think we're doing an ASMR stream tomorrow if I'm not mistaken
Uh
Yeah, we're doing ASMR stream tomorrow. So
Um, I'll see you tomorrow and it's gonna be really fun because everyone's doing an ASMR stream tomorrow
And we're gonna be rating into each other. So you'll have like a full day of ASMR
If you have the day free that is so yeah, um, can we get a good boy?
You want another good boy?
Okay, okay, okay, okay. Thank you for coming. Um, I know there was something specific. It was like
You you worked very hard today and you're you're a very good boy for me
I feel a little awkward saying it. I'm like shy. I get shy about
it
Um, thank you for coming. Um
And and and um
I'll see you tomorrow
Um, yeah, bye. Bye pookie
Oh